I actually went to audition for Jerry
Maguire and the store with that Tom
Cruise is doing you know Jerry Maguire
so they had the guy sees me read and L
latest Jack I want you to go to read
440c in New York I said Who t see Tom
for the hollow taco so I go to read but
as I'm reading I'm loud show me the
money Tom Cruise his line but it was
like this so I thought he'd lost his
place here some we right he says I know
I said the line I'm waiting on you I
might go blind the whole night anyway I
didn't get the part and you know of
course you know
Cuba Gooding got the part in in any one
awesome but I had to learn how to bring
it down and then later on I did
collateral with Tom Cruise and then got
nominated for
[Applause]
I like the theory though I like the
story of learning that like Tom Cruise
was the star was here oh yeah well and
that was the other thing too when I did
get in collateral you know I was sort of
like Michael Mann was like hey you
better get keep your stuff together cuz
I'm you know making sure this movie
works with it for the big star and
that's how I knew I wasn't a big star
we're in the car and we're driving was
supposed to do this stunt where I crash
into another car right but it's supposed
to be a stunt but what happens is the
car gets out of out of control and I
actually do crash into the car like
Jamie get out of the way Tom are you
okay
that's where you know where you are
[Music]
telling me you've never met I use even
to see something have you never
satisfied even to be something really
have you never met a spice girl I'm wait
hold on have you never miss almost a
spider-man link because it starts off
with lights out like a power outage
lights out like a power
[Applause]